どうしてもピザが食べたい後輩っていう設定で
了解です
アクション
ああ、そうゆう事
そそそ
くそ、課金してえな
はじめさん
ピザ食べたいんですけど
ピザ食べたい？
ピザ食べたいです
まじかーーー
いや、マジで、ピザ食いたいです
でも俺も腹へってんだよなー
はい
じゃあ～…デリバリー頼むか
はい頼みましょう
はいというわけで今回はピザを頼んでいこうと思いｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
あのただピザを頼んでもあれだから、
そうです
ピザを頼むときに何かしらのアドを稼ぎたいから、
ピザを頼む上で何かプラスな要素があれば
一番、頼んでていいじゃんね
今回は自分たちにアドを課しましょう
けっこう体が凝ってるので、
というわけで今から、後輩がど～してもピザが食べたいって言うので、
ピザを注文するんですけども、
受けとるときについでにまあマッサージもしてたいと。
ピザを頼むだけで、おいしいピザも食べれるし、体も癒せる
後輩「アドやん（笑）」
後「やばい×４ｗｗｗ」
電気マッサージ器を体中につけて、体をマッサージしながら、今回はピザを受け取ろうと思います。
まあピザを受け取る時間は短いので、くまなく全身をマッサージするために
なるべくたくさんの電気マッサージ器を準備したので
これを体につけていきましょう。
ほんと、だって、マッサージ器具でしょ！？
後「ま、たしかにね！使用用途それだよ」
ピザを受け取るときになんかマッサージしながら来ると態度が悪いって思われるから、
マッサージしてないような装いをして
自然と受け取る、ピザを。それが、ピザの店員さんに対する礼儀なんで。
それをバレないようにやっていきたいと思います。
はい、マッサージ器の準備できました！
今から電話でピザ屋さんに注文するんですけども、
まあもう注文から体中に電気マッサージ器をつけて注文していきたいと思います。
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
体中に電気マッサージ器がついたので、あそこのスイッチですね、このスイッチ一つ押せば、
もう僕は体中でマッサージが起きるという。
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”やばい×３、ちょっちょっちょ
後「耐えないと、ダメっすから」
それはたしかに。
あ”う”う”う”う”う”やばいやばい×(測定不能)
まじすごいまじすごい
後「これいけるんすかｗｗｗ」
もう頼むしかないこれは。じゃあさっそく、ピザ屋さんに電話します。
ピザ屋「こんばんは！」あ、すいません、えっとピザ注文したいんですけど、ピ「はい、ありがとうございます」
ピ「えっと、デリバリーか商品お持ち帰りか
ピ「デリバリーで！」はい、えーっと一応二人なんで
クワトロフォルマッジのMを一つで
ピ「生地のサイズが3種類あるんですけれども、」
ピ「ミルフィーユでよろしいですか？」はい。
会話中
ピ「はい、ではお会計が税込みで2970円になりますので、お届け時にお会計の方お願いします」はい、よろしくお願いします。
はい
あ”あ”あ失礼します！
後「あははｗｗｗこれやばっ！やばいでしょこれ！」ねえ汗、汗見て！
では、ピザが届くのを待ちましょお”お”お”
ちなみに毎回、ドミノピザの
動画を撮ったあと、ドミノピザの公式アカウントから
「お買い上げありがとうございました」とメッセージをいただいております。
いつもご迷惑してごめんなさい。…行きましょう！！
こんにちは～すいませんこんにちは～
ピ「来た道わかんなかったんですが(?)」　あ、すいません申し訳ないです
すいません、ありがとうございます
(スイッチオン)
あ”あ”あ”あ”あ”
一万円で！
ありがとうございました！
あ”あ”あ”いたーーーーーーーー